from the outset we have trusted in the
common sense and perseverance of the
British people and their response has
more than justified our faith since I
set out our plan on the 11th of May we
have been clear that our cautious
relaxation of the guidance is entirely
conditional on our continued defeat over
the virus in the first half of May
nearly sixty nine thousand people tested
positive for coded 19 across the UK by
the first half of June that total had
fallen by nearly 70 percent to just
under 22,000 the number of new
infections is now declining by between 2
and 4 percent every day four weeks ago
an average of one in 400 people in the
community in England had covered 19 in
the first half of June this figure was 1
in 1700 we created a human shield around
the NHS and in turn our doctors and
nurses have protected us and together we
have saved our hospitals from being
overwhelmed on the 11th of May 1070
three people were admitted to hospital
in England Wales and Northern Ireland
with kavett 19 by the 20th of June this
had fallen by 74 percent to 283 this
pandemic has inflicted permanent scars
and we mourn everyone we have lost
measured by a seven-day rolling average
the number of daily deaths peaked at 943
on the 14th of April on the 11th of May
it was 476 and yesterday the rolling
average stood at 130 we've ordered over
2.2 billion items of protective
equipment from uk-based manufacturers
many of whose production lines have been
called into being to serve this new
demand and yesterday we conducted or
posted 130 9659
tests bringing the total to over 8
million and while we remain vigilant we
do not believe there is currently
currently a risk of a second peak of
infections that might overwhelm the NHS
taking everything together we continue
to meet our five tests and the chief
medical officers of all four Home
Nations have downgraded the UK's covert
alert level from four to three meaning
we no longer face a virus spreading
exponentially though it remains in
general circulation the administration's
in Scotland Wales and Northern Ireland
hold responsibility for their own
lockdown restrictions and they will
respond to the United hue of the chief
medical officers at their own pace based
on their own judgement but all parts of
the UK are now travelling in the same
direction and we will continue to work
together to ensure that everyone in our
country gets the support they need
thanks to our progress we can now go
further and safely ease the lockdown in
England
at every stage caution will remain our
watch work and each step will be
conditional and reversible mr. speaker
given the significant fall in the
prevalence of the virus we can change
the 2 meter social distancing rule from
the 4th of July I know this rule
effectively makes life impossible for
large parts of our economy even without
other restrictions for example it
prevents all but a fraction of our
hospitality industry from operating
that's why almost two weeks ago I asked
our experts to conduct a review and I
will place a summary of their
conclusions in the libraries of both
houses this week where it is possible to
keep 2 meters apart people should but
where it is not we will advise people to
keep a social distance of 1 meter Plus
meaning they should remain one meter
apart while taking mitigations to reduce
the risk of transmission and we are
today publishing guidance on how
business can reduce the risk by taking
certain steps to protect workers and
customers and these include for instance
avoiding face to face seating by
changing office layouts reducing the
number of people in enclosed spaces
improving ventilation using protective
screens and face coverings closing
non-essential social spaces providing
hand sign and sanitizer changing a shift
pattern so that staff work in set teams
and of course we already mandate face
coverings on public transport while the
experts cannot give a precise assessment
of how much the risk is reduced
they judge these mitigations would make
one meter plus broadly equivalent to the
risk at two meters
if those mitigations are fully
implemented so either will
acceptable and our guidance will change
accordingly and this vital change
enables the next stage of our plan to
ease the lockdown a mr. speaker I'm
acutely conscious that people will ask
legitimate questions about why certain
activities are allowed and others are
not and I must ask the house to
understand that the virus has no
interest in these debates it's only
interest it's only eight ambition is to
exploit any opportunities to recapture
ground that we might carelessly vacate
and to reinfect
our communities and so there is only one
certainty the fewer social contacts you
have the safer you will be and my GTR
Duty is the government is to guide the
British people balancing our overriding
aim of controlling the virus against our
natural desire to bring back normal life
we cannot lift all the restrictions at
once so we have to make difficult
judgments and every step is scrupulous
we weighed against the evidence our
principle is to trust the British public
to use their common sense in the full
knowledge of the risks remembering that
the more we open up the more vigilant we
will need to be from now on we will ask
people to follow guidance on social
contact instead of legislation in that
spirit we advise we advise us from the
fourth of July to households of any size
should be able to meet in any setting
inside or out that does not mean they
must always be the same too
households it will be possible for
instance to meet one set of grandparents
one weekend the others are the following
weekend but we are not we are not
recommending meetings of multiple
households indoors because of the risks
of creating greater chains of
transmission outside the guidance
remains the people from several
households can meet in groups of up to
six and it follows that two households
can also meet regardless of size
Mr Speaker I can tell the house that we
were also reopen restaurants and pubs
all hospitality indoors will be limited
to table service and our guidance will
encourage minimal staff and customer
contact we will ask businesses to help
NHS tests increase respond to any local
outbreaks by collecting contact details
from customers as happens in other
countries and we will work with the
sector to make this manageable almost as
easily awaited as a pint will be a
haircut do you buy me as a speaker and
so we will reopen hairdressers and with
appropriate precautions including the
use of visors